what's up y'all it's Jaden Ivy here I'm
with Bleacher Report and tiso the
official watch of the NBA
what's up bro how you doing York good to
see you
that's out of bounds Memphis
that's crazy I was been competing with
Jaden since he was like 14 or 15 years
old he's always been able to compete you
know you were always in the gym you were
running two miles on the track before
the workout even started so at that
point in time I knew okay he's gonna be
special he's gonna be different you
embody what it what a person should be
like in this life
um so I thank you and I thank you for
believing in me and I can remember all
the times that you motivated me to be
the best version of myself as well so
sure and I got a special gift for you
t-so watch hope you like it bro wow
that's amazing bro yeah that's sharp
that's real sharp I like it thank you
bro